I'm going to talk for a few minutes about this memory question.
There's a
article assigned to the very end of the reading packet that you perhaps read by
now,
I hope piece I wrote some years ago,
which gives you a kind of a breezy take on some of the complexities of how the
civil war and reconstruction have been remembered in the United States.
It is arguably the most vexing piece of our pass for our larger political public
culture to process.
You can simply do it this way though.
This is one of the people that Tony Horowitz interviewed in his wonderful book,
confederates in the attic with some of you may have read quite popular book that
came out about five years ago,
Horwitz,
a great journalist,
did a travel book all over the South and tried to come to some grips and
understanding
of many things,
but particularly of civil war buffs and civil war enthusiasm of why this event
in doors so much in our popular culture.
Among the people he interviewed was this guy who said,
quote,
I think there's a lot of people like me.
I want to get back to a simpler time.
Sandlot,
baseball cowboys and Indians and the civil war.
Just take me away wherever my president is,
whatever my life is,
just transform port me till the morning of July 3rd at Gettysburg or some other
place
that was a musician and interviewed on NPR yesterday morning who's been through
a horrible life of drugs and alcohol addiction.
The end of it,
he was asked to give the biggest influences on his recovery and his survival and
he said,
well,
certain artists,
certain people,
but mostly the civil war.
Great,
and that's where the interview ended.
I was dying to find out what the hell did that mean?
Good God Almighty,
but God blessing.
All right legacies,
everything in history has a legacy.
We'll use the term all the time.
Oh,
legacies of this and the legacies of that,
the legacies of that event.
What are the legacies of World War Two?
What are the legacies of the civil rights movement?
But what is the legacy stop for just a second with me?
How many attempt definition?
Some Tim,
it can be simply another word for historical of how we remember things and then
how we using them.
It always carries some current present and often political meaning if you use
the term legacy for something,
it probably has a current political stake.
Reconstruction in our history wasn't ongoing referendum on the meaning and
legacies of slavery and the civil war and so much of our racial history,
our constitutional history or political history ever since reconstruction has
been a referendum on the meaning and memory of reconstruction.
Was there a reconciliation in the wake of these events have sections of states
of soldiers of the political class or have masters and slaves,
blacks and whites who got reconcile
and who didn't.
Legacies I'd suggest can be emotional.
Test this with your parents
are your grandparents.
Legacies can be emotional,
they can be intellectual,
they can be physical,
it can be financial.
They can be about habits.
They surely can be political and they can be sacred or secular and my parents
were the great depression and then World War II generation and it was all over
them.
My father always feared insurance.
You always want to know exact.
He had no money,
but he always wanna know exactly where is his money was.
He almost kept it under a pillow and it was stupid.
It was crazy,
but after the depression and five farm foreclosures that his family had,
he couldn't stand.
Letting anyone else have is a couple thousand dollars.
That's a legacy of the Great Depression.
It's a habit.
It's a point of view and it's a set of assumptions.
This event
had so many legacies that frankly we just keep adding to them with the time.
They just don't really go away.
Sometimes a legacy is perhaps what is simply leftover out in public memory and
our behavior and our policies.
After historians have written all their books,
museums have mounted all their exhibitions.
Teachers have taught their classes.
Elders have tried to instruct the young at the grassroots level and in families.
A legacy is that which endures all of our filterings,
all of our debates,
all of our struggles over controlling the story we say we live in.
It is where
the past and the present meet,
and there's no event in American history that's caused more of these struggles.
There are others that compare.
There's no event.
It's caused more struggles over just how the past and present meat than our
civil war.
Just take some of these ideas is physical legacies,
emotional legacies.
If you took the number of dead in the American civil war,
yeah.
And you moved it to the present per capita,
13 million Americans would die in a war.
Today.
Slavery was gone.
Anger at its loss had no end
in the south.
The economy and the physical landscape was in collapse.
Two thirds of southern wealth of the x confederate states was destroyed in four
years.
And a lot of that wealth,
of course,
was slaves.
Three and a half billion dollars worth
40% of all sudden livestock were dead.
At the end of the war,
50% of all farm machinery destroyed.
It was an enormous refugee problem.
Mobilization had occurred,
unmatched.
It will be unmatched until World War II.
Okay.
And in the south in particular,
the war had killed approximately,
uh,
killed or incapacitated,
excuse me,
one of every four males from the age of 16 to 45.
How do you process that kind of loss and destruction and violence and a society
that must find a way to reconcile it?
Can't send the defeated part somewhere else or could have tried but Brazil and
take them all.
Okay.
Certainly Britain wouldn't take him all Mexico couldn't,
wouldn't.
How would this reconciliation actually come?
I was doing research
at the Huntington Library a couple of years ago
and I was actually there to give a lecture and I was,
I had two days to kill.
I was just playing around on the Ellen Nevins papers.
Ellen Evans was a great civil wars storing back in the fifties and sixties I
grew up reading his works and I was actually giving a lecture name for Alan
Nevin,
so I thought it's got a couple of days in the Nevins papers and just just lose
myself and nothing better in the world other than teaching this class and losing
yourself in a great library for two days with no agenda.
I'm following through the Nevins papers of huge collection and I just bumped
into an essay in manuscript form by my hero,
Bruce Catton.
I've mentioned him before,
grew up reading his books,
still on it happened Maddix and so many others.
The great popular historian of the civil war in the 50 60 seventies and here was
this little essay by Catton entitled the end of the Centennial,
1965 not the day centennial
of the US civil war.
Captain Nevins had been themselves directors,
executive directors,
presidents and vice presidents,
whatever they were called of the u s centennial commission for the civil war,
a commission.
That was in many ways a debacle because it was all occurring.
Again.
Think of the dates at the time of the civil rights movement.
Anyway,
I had just published a book on civil war memory this long tome,
and here comes this the last day,
and I was thinking,
Oh,
Bruce Catton,
I'm sure he'll agree with me
now,
and this essay,
which was later published,
I discovered and cat and wrote it in 1965 he muses about memory and you use the
actual word memory,
and that that was reassuring because I was writing about memory in a world and a
world of academics who were over there.
I was,
were very suspicious about what the hell this idea of memory was supposed to
mean.
He marveled in this piece and how Americans had healed.
That was his word from their civil war,
from this kind of bloodletting,
how a nation of or a hundred years had healed,
he said,
and that a nation could actually commemorate us,
civil war so openly,
all over the landscape.
He said,
was truly remarkable,
if not unprecedented in modern history.
The war,
he said was his word,
a source of unity.
The memory of our civil war,
and I'm quoting Bruce Catton,
1965 has not been a divisive force in this country.
I had one of those moments where I said,
Oh God,
Bruce say it ain't so,
you didn't say that
reminded me of the time I ran into my greatest baseball hero ever on airport.
Probably don't even know him.
Al Kayline,
the right fielder for the Detroit Tigers,
the one and only LK line,
only Roberto Clemente could even come close to Caitlin is a right to run into an
airport once end of his career and I was about 28 and he was smoking
a cigarette.
Damn,
don't meet your heroes.
How could Bruce have written that sentence?
And I just written a 500 page book that argued exactly the opposite
for forging all this unit I read on in the essay for forging all of this unity.
He gave most of the credit to grant and Lee at Appa Maddix and the nature of the
surrender,
the compassionate character of that surrender at Appomattox.
Okay.
But then he went on.
He said primarily he gave credit to what he called the confederate legend,
which he described as,
I'm quoting him,
a mighty omnipresent force in the land.
In all seriousness,
it's all quoting captain.
The legend of the loss cause has been an asset to the entire country
and that just blew me away.
Okay.
Oh Bruce,
please tell me you didn't write that
captains portrayal of the law causing this essay was that of a benign innocent
romantic cluster of legends about the old south driven by the assumption as he
put it,
that quote,
no hint of enmities should ever be kept
alive.
His laws cause in the brevity of one essay was a story of noble sacrifice by the
south and heroism of an astrologer for an older civilization that had been some
kind of bull work against modernism and Indian as cat and put it the confederate
legend,
the loss,
cause he said,
quote saved us.
I couldn't really take it anymore.
At the very end of the essay,
Caton
redeemed himself a bit.
He acknowledged that in 1965 the war had left.
He said the unfinished business of black equality as its deepest legacy.
And that quote,
the Negro was what the war was about somehow.
Now that was probably a ribbon given how closely Caton new Lincoln loved
Lincoln.
I was probably a riff on Lincoln's use of the word.
Somehow in the second inaugural or Lincoln says somehow all knew the war was
about slavery.
And we've been trying to explain that somehow in our 65 to 70,000 books on the
civil well at some of them have
ever since.
Now
I remember rising from that thinking,
well I just lost another hero.
How could Bruce Catton of settle all of this?
Well,
for one thing,
he never did any research on the lost cause.
He didn't know the laws cause they didn't know that the lost cause became
essentially a racial ideology,
that it became a cluster of legends as he put it.
But a cluster of legends in the service of white supremacy.
A few assumptions in search of a history
and any ideology that came to be the buttressing,
the base of Jim Crow America.
But then I started thinking more and more and I began to realize,
don't be emotional about this.
Okay.
Bruce Catton was actually in 1965 capturing absolutely capturing the mainstream
American conception of the lost cause and a civil war memory
that the south heroism that the confederacy's effort to stake all on the line
for its independence,
that the glorious figure of a Robert E.
Lee,
the steadfastness of a Jefferson Davis had indeed become national phenomenon.
Captain was just summing up the mainstream of American thought by the 1960s
and that old cliche that you've heard perhaps before many times at the south
lost the war,
but one of the piece or the south lost the war,
but one of the debate over the memory,
what's basically what captain was summing up.
I think captain believed this too,
but I let him off the hook
because by circa 1965 the understanding of the American civil war and the broad
mainstream culture,
not among most African Americans and now a new young generation of historians
who came of age in the wake of World War Two and we're deeply interested in the
problem of race in American history as never before and deeply inspired by an
anthropological,
sociological,
psychological revolution and the study of race.
We're beginning to write about it differently.
The great southern poet who lives much of his life,
much of the second half of his life right here and whose papers are right there,
the [inaudible] Robert Penn Warren wrote brilliantly about this and a little
book,
a little less say action big essay in a little book that he wrote in 1961 called
the legacy of the civil war.
You wrote it for life magazine and was later published as a book in that book,
trying to capture what the meaning of the civil war wasn't American culture a
Hundred Years After Ken Warren said that somewhere in their bones,
and I quote him,
most Americans have a storehouse of lessons drawn from the civil war.
Okay.
Oh,
exactly what those lessons should be.
Has it been,
I think the most contested question in America's historical memory over and over
again,
at least since 1865 and probably even since 1863 when the warrant or went or
revolution
among all the possible lessons of our civil war road,
Robert Penn Warren is the realization,
his words that slavery looms up mountainous Lee in the story and cannot be
talked away.
Okay.
Our culture has spent nearly now a century and a half and it is still at it of
talking away the place of slavery and this event and its place in the aftermath.
When one is happy and forgetfulness said,
Penn Warren facts get forgotten.
Or as William Dean Howells put it in 1900 and I think I quote this in the essay
you've read with the American people always like is a tragedy as long as they
can give it a happy ending.
Okay.
We have a tragic sensibility as a culture,
as long as we can,
I can see an exit from it.
All right.
Let me just give you three hooks to hang your hat on in terms of how Americans
have processed this memory.
Um,
I've labeled them reconciliation as white supremacist and emancipation is,
and they simply mean this.
There are some other ways of thinking about how civil war memory was processed,
but most of them can come under these categories.
A reconciliation,
his vision of this war took root in the midst of the war.
It took root,
especially in dealing with all the dead
and files.
A new book on this called Republican suffering is a must read if you stay
interested in this subject.
I'm conducting an interview with her tomorrow night in New York about that book.
I've talked to so many people keep telling me they can't read past page 50
because it's so depressing
and I usually say something stupid like it's good for you.
Take your pill.
The reconciliation is vision of this war.
I mean somehow putting ourselves back together is rooted right there and putting
bodies back together and then putting hundreds of thousands of bodies in the
ground
and files the book as never before.
We are taken literally into those graves.
She found tremendous evidence of what soldiers themselves did on battlefields to
bury their own dead and sometimes even bury the enemy to give people decent
human burials after they'd been half eaten by dogs.
Nothing like burying a dead man without a coffin on a battlefield that you've
known.
We'll make you pray and beg to be reconciled with something
but a second kind of civil war memory
if we can call it.
That was the white supremacists memory,
which took many forms early,
including of course the terror and violence of the Klan and its many imitators
in reconstruction and then locked arms eventually in the later 19th century and
into the 20th century with reconciliation is the of all kinds and our culture
and delivered the country a racially segregated memory,
a racially segregated story of this experience at least by 1900 and really even
before
a third kind of memory,
always competing with these,
we might call an emancipation,
this memory embodied in African Americans complex and they have no single memory
of slavery.
The warm emancipation and reconstruction and Nero complex remembrance of what
slavery and their freedom had meant to them,
but an emancipation,
his vision of the civil war was also rooted in the politics of radical
reconstruction.
Also rooted in the three constitutional amendments and conceptions of the war as
a reinvention of the republic and the liberation of blacks to citizenship,
blacks,
and eventually others to constitutional quality.
In the end once you have here is a story eventually of how the forces of
reconciliation overwhelmed
that emancipation,
his vision in the national culture and how an inexorable drive for reunion of
north and south both used race and then trumped it,
but the story doesn't just dead end.
Okay.
And this white supremacy victory,
this lost cause victory because eventually the loss cause wasn't about causes.
Lost it all.
The lost causes.
He ology of the south became a victory narrative and the victory they argued was
a national victory over reconstruction.
If you want to say,
if you want to ask,
what was the biggest success in the long struggle over civil war memory?
It was the of the loss caused ideology in selling themselves to northerners who
bought in and said,
yes,
the nation has finally triumphed over the mistake of reconstruction.
But there was a fledgling neo abolitionists tradition that emancipation,
his vision of the civil war and never died.
A permanent death in American culture by any means kept alive by blacks,
black leadership and white allies.
Yeah.
There is a persistence of that memory that frankly folks made possible the civil
rights revolution of the fifties and sixties and it was happening even before
the 50s
okay.
But if one thing in particular happen to the memory of the civil war,
it found its way eventually into a broad consensus.
In the broader national culture,
there was never an animus of course,
but in a broader national culture that somehow in this war and this Armageddon
in this blood letting everybody had been right,
nobody had been wrong.
You want to reconcile a country that's had a horrifying civil war.
How do you do it?
Okay,
well,
you start building thousands upon thousands of monument.
You started having soldier reunions.
You've read about the Gettysburg reunion in this essay of mine.
I won't even go into that.
The biggest of all the blue gray reunions,
which became a Jim crow reunion by 1913 and Ken Burns did not tell you that in
his film and played a very interesting trick on you without editing button by
showing you black and white veterans at the 1913 reunion,
shaking hands and,
and,
and an irresistible beautiful emotional moment.
The trouble is those veterans were shaking hands 25 years later in 1938 at the,
at the uh,
new deal reunion at Gettysburg.
They weren't there in 1913 but in the film,
that's certainly what it looks like.
Okay.
Power of filmmaking.
It was a popular novel published in 1912 Zulian popular novels published about
the civil war,
but this one was by a southern woman writer,
a very interesting writer.
We don't read much today if anybody reads her,
although she was important in her time.
Her name was Mary Johnston.
Okay.
She was a Virginian born to the upper crust of Virginia planter life born just
after the war.
She was imbued with the loss cause tradition,
but grew up wanting to interrogate it a little bit.
She was a lost cause her but,
but she asks questions about it.
She became a suffragist,
a real progressive woman in so many ways.
She wrote a trilogy of civil war books,
her most famous book,
and it was a huge best seller,
was called to have and to hold one of her trilogy is a novel called cease
firing,
which also was a near best seller.
Yeah.
And cease firing on the last page of the book.
She has Lee's army retreating from Richmond out toward their surrender.
It happen Maddix and she's a good writer.
And literally on the last two pages she has two confederate soldiers in their
rags,
half starved in conversation
and one of these old veterans as to the other.
What do you thinks it all means?
What?
What's it all about brother
and the other answers and says,
I think that we were both right and both wrong.
And then in the beginning each side might've been more patient and much wiser
life and history and right and wrong in the minds of men.
Look out of more windows than we used to think.
Did you never hear of the shield that had two sides and both were made of
precious metal?
Yeah.
Why didn't we just get along?
We were both right.
No,
that's an honest sentiment.
She puts in the mouths of a of a half star of confederate veteran who the lucky
to be alive and is now either about to dessert or surrender to the union army.
Neither option of which he ever hope to live to have to face.
And she also captures in that moment a very honest sentiment that it's city and
all over American culture,
especially in veterans culture and all those blue gray reunions and the Getty's
were blue,
gray reunion was about to occur the following year after this book was
published.
And that is the sense of the mutuality of sacrifice among soldiers
cure
the hatreds of war
by bringing the warriors together
cause they have a mutuality of experience.
Yeah.
But there was a,
and there was of course,
no lack of honor at Appa Maddix on either side.
Yeah.
But outside of all that Paso's that,
that understanding,
that sentiment that Americans in born in Dubai,
the millions,
there was of course another whole story going on out in them in American culture
and in national memory.
In 1912 the NAACP counted 72 lynchings in America and about 90% of whom are
African Americans.
By 1912 when that book was published,
the entire Jim crow legal system in all of its absurdities was fully in place
roughly by about 1910 across the south and in some of the border states and to
some extent even in the north.
Okay.
Any ratio,
a cultural,
historical mnemonic e ratio had been going on for three,
four and five decades
of emancipation.
Okay.
From the national narrative of what this war had even ever been about.
That process led the great black scholar Wb Dubois the same year in 1912 and the
crisis magazine,
the Journal of Naacp to conclude as he put it,
this country
has had its appetite for facts on the civil war and the Negro problem spoiled by
sweets.
They eating too much candy.
We give you one other example from one of these other blue gray reunion by the
1890s these weren't easy to do.
These,
these blue gray reunion is bringing back and federal union veterans to all
battlefields or sites and cities and so forth.
These weren't easy to do.
They first attempted doing it in the 1870s confederates didn't want to come to
these things.
1880s even.
It wasn't easy to do.
They had won at Gettysburg on the 20th anniversary and on the 25th anniversary.
But it's hard,
especially to get a confederates to go to Gettysburg,
the scene of their worst defeat.
But by the 1890s 25 years out now and 30 years out from the war with the
transmission,
and we know this about so many events in the way generations learn from one
another and the way memory gets passed on as soon as there is truly a
generational transition,
the old veterans as they get older,
are willing to come.
The 1900 blue gray reunion was held in Atlanta and by the way,
southern cities started to compete for these things.
It's like northern cities because they were huge.
Moneymakers thousands and thousands of veterans would come with their families
and spend thousands and thousands of dollars.
Anyway,
in 1900 the blue gray was in Atlanta
and during the major speeches at that reunion,
the commander of the GAA are the grand army of the republic.
The big northern a veteran's organization was a guy named Sean from
Massachusetts,
no relation to Robert Gould,
Shaw of the famous 54th mass and in his speech he lectured the confederate
veterans is sky,
had a lot of New England Chutzpah.
He lectured them about their efforts to school textbooks,
which by the way,
all veterans organizations were absolutely doing.
Every confederate Veterans Organization had its textbook committee and many
union veterans post and organizations had their textbook committee.
They were competing with one another to control the story in American textbooks
and trying to lobby and control publishers.
Anyway,
commanders show was a little exercised about this and he said among other
things,
quote,
and you can almost see a sort of school in Garmisch finger wagging and what he
says,
he said,
quote,
keeping alive sectional teachings as to the Justice and rights of the cause of
the south in the hearts of your children is all out of order.
It is unwise and unjust.
Hmm.
The commander of the United confederate veterans was none other than John Be
Gordon [inaudible].
Gordon had been a confederate general.
John B.
Gordon was the confederate general in charge of the stacking of the arms and the
surrender at Appomattox.
John [inaudible] Gordon and went on to get elected senator governor and then
senator from Georgia during reconstruction.
He was also one of the founders of the Ku Klux Klan in Georgia all the way.
Lied through his teeth and the KKK hearings of 1871 about it,
but John Be Gordon by the 1890s became one of the most ubiquitous and popular
confederate memorial day speakers and he was good at it.
He got up to respond to commanders Shaw,
and this is a final passage in what he said,
John,
be Gordon 1900 head of the UCV United confederate veterans when he tells me in
my southern comrades are the teaching our children,
that the cause for which we fought and our comrades died is all wrong.
I must earnestly protest in the name of the future man hood of the south.
I protest.
What are we to teach to them if we cannot teach them that their fathers were
right?
It follows that these southern children must be taught that they were wrong.
I never will be ready to have my children taught that I was ever wrong or that
the cause of my people was unjust,
an unholy.
All my friends,
you were right,
but we were right to
everybody was right.
Nobody was wrong
in a war that killed 620,000 people and maimed about 1.2 million and transform
the society,
but no one was wrong.
Okay?
In fact,
by the 18 nine is a big as it is still today became very popular
to be a confederate veteran.
If you've read Tony Horowitz's confederates in the attic,
he showed how so many civil war reenactors,
it appears still today,
prefer to reenact then the reenact unionists,
although the lots of union reenactors and I know lots of black reenactors,
which raises a fascinating,
uh,
intellectual question,
which we don't have to dwell on now.
And that is why his defeat sometimes more interesting than victory.
Ask yourselves that.
Why do those Nazis never disappear from the bookstore shelves?
Often right up front
Nazis,
dogs in the civil war is the publisher sometimes tell you if you're right about
those,
we'll buy it.
We'll sell it.
Hate being in that category.
Okay.
And then there are those who will say things like Nazis,
Holocaust memoirs,
dogs on the civil war,
horses too.
Big Deal here in the horses.
Anyway,
the confederate veteran magazine,
which become a very popular magazine in the 1890s and lasting like 35 years into
the 20th century,
ran this little story in 1894
it reported a story of a southern woman,
a white woman,
and her son attending a production of theater production in Brooklyn,
New York of the play called Hell by the enemy and theater productions plays
about the civil war,
especially with some kind of reconciliation is theme became wildly popular by
the 1890s the boy sitting there with his mother,
according to the anonymous author,
ask his mother,
what did the Yankees fight for mother,
and as the orchestra strikes up marching through Georgia,
the woman answers for the union darling.
Painful memories were told,
bring sadness to the mother's face as she hears the Yankee Victory Song and then
earnestly the boy asks,
what did the confederates fight for mother
and before the mother can answer the music changes to home sweet home,
which fills the theater,
says the author with its depth of untold melody and Patheos.
The mother whispers are answered to her son.
Do you hear what they are playing?
That is what confederates fought for,
darling and the boy counters.
Did they fight for their homes?
Okay.
And with the parents assurance,
the boy burst into tears and with what the author calls the intuition of,
right,
he hugs his mother and announces,
Oh mother,
I will be a confederate.
No,
just fought for their homes.
That's all you needed to know.
No,
maybe all a mother would want a little boy to know.
But all over American culture
there were millions
who didn't really want to know anymore.
Everybody was right.
Nobody was wrong.
There are a hundred ways to plant this story or examples through which to tell
this story and I don't want to take really any more time on it.
Uh,
you can read a book called race and reunion if it ever,
so moves you.
I want to get to our review.
Yes,
I am getting to our review,
but I do want to leave you with this thought.
The two images,
if I can,
uh,
three images actually.
Okay.
Or two metaphors.
One,
I guess isn't quite a metaphor.
In the second chapter of Dubois is the souls of black folk.
Okay,
I'm going to test how many of you've read souls of black folk.
I know we got work to do it.
Yale,
no one should have a degree from Yale without reading souls of black folk.
No one should have US citizenship without reading folds the black book,
but since I don't rule the world,
who cares?
Chapter two of Dubois,
his masterpiece is an essay he called the dawn of freedom.
He starts out extensively as an essay on a kind of a little history of the
Freedman's bureau and a little take on reconstruction,
but he turns it into much,
much more.
It turns it into a meditation,
Not Unlike Penn Warren,
we'll do an 90 61 but a meditation on the meaning and memory of slavery,
the civil war and reconstruction,
and he goes into a discussion is only do boys could cause.
Dubois was really a poet,
historian or historian has poet.
He begins to discuss how bleak life actually is on the ground and the south,
not just for the Friedman as sharecroppers,
but for whites as well.
That poverty is a black and white thing.
He says he's got another chapter to come in the book called the black belt where
he shows that poverty is something southern is share if they would.
Okay.
And then he stops and he says in effect,
see this picture with me through what he calls two figures.
He says there are two figures in his view that typified the postwar era
and the power of its legacies.
Here's the passage.
Two figures as Dubois is quote the One uh,
Gray hair gentlemen whose had quit themselves like men whose son's laying
nameless graves who bowed to the evil of slavery because its abolition
threatened untold ill to all who stood at last in the evening of life.
A ruin form with Hayden is on
your first figure is an old white man,
probably a former planter who's lost everything.
He's bitter.
I mean he's,
he's really bitter,
okay.
He feels a burden of southern history,
none.
Dubois says,
and the other form hovering dark and mother like her awful face,
black with the myths of centuries had a four time quail that that White Masters
Command had been in love over the cradles of his sons and daughters and closed
in death.
The sunken eyes of his wife and I to at his behest had laid herself low to his
lust and born atony man child to the world only to see her dark boys limbs
scattered to the winds by midnight marauders riding after damn niggers.
Second image,
an old black woman,
former slave
mami,
but also broken.
No future.
It doesn't even know where that sun might be in the sun is probably dead,
but do boys presses the issue?
The boys?
Is that a genuine sense of tragedy?
And he didn't care sometimes whether we gave you a happy ending,
he pressed the issue.
He says,
then these were the saddest sites.
I'm quoting of that Woelfel day and no man clasp the hands of these passing
figures of the present past legacy.
We're past and present.
Meet no man.
Clasp the hands of these passing figures of the present past.
But hating,
they went to their long home and hating their children's children live today.
Now,
unmistakably Dubois is using that language of clasping hands for a purpose
because it's by far the most ubiquitous image used and all the blue gray
reunions by the 90s he first wrote this essay in 1897 and revise it,
the souls of black folk in 1903 but the most ubiquitous image and all the blue
gray reunions was then,
in fact,
the slogan was clasping hands across the bloody chasm
and the shaking of hands of the blue and the gray,
the old confederate Yvette's,
the old union vets was always the the,
you know the,
the photo op and it's all over the ending of burns.
This film.
How can it,
how could you and how can you resist it in some ways,
what can be more beautiful than old,
old men chest full of medals,
shaking hands across the walls.
They tried to kill each other over.
There's something human about that that we can't quite resist.
But Dubois says,
you know what?
There are two other kinds of veterans of the civil war and no one's ever class
with their hands
and that will just ask you to think.
I don't not doing this for any political partisan reason.
I don't know if you've read it,
but at the very end of Barack Obama's race speech,
I'm talking about Obama now was a historian not as a candidate.
He's got enough problems with it.
Reverend Wright right now,
this is Obama,
the writer,
and I don't know if he read chapter two of souls before he wrote that speech in
Philadelphia month ago.
Doesn't really matter if he did.
I don't remember if you're read to the end of it,
if you've read it or if you heard it.
I know I've actually never heard it.
I've only read it,
but the way he ended that speech is the way a lot of politicians get up on the
stump and talk and at first you're ready to dismiss it.
It's another one of those stories of,
I met somebody on the campaign trail.
Here's what she said to me,
and she had this terrible story to tell.
Let me tell you her terrible story
and you start tuning out.
Oh God,
here comes another story of old aunt something or other and on welfare or
whatever,
but no,
it's a story of a young 23 year old white woman named Ashley by year who is his
campaign manager in Florence,
South Carolina,
and he remembered the story of when he,
during the South Carolina primary,
it was doing an event in Florence,
South Carolina.
He meets Ashley and Ashley tells him her story and that story is and brief that
she grew up with a single mother,
poor,
poor white girl in the south at age about town.
Her mother got cancer,
lost a job,
family went bankrupt,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
In order to help out her mother's told the story of eating nothing but mustard
and relish sandwiches for a year,
a year and a half.
Apparently her mother survive,
but they never really don't survive with the bankruptcy,
but somehow as she got older,
she got interested in politics.
Now that's a white working lower working class,
poor southern girl who had every right to be in that group do.
Obama had described earlier who are the whites in America with a lot of
resentment of all the racial changes in America.
Instead she becomes his campaign manager and she put together this whole
gathering in Florence and some,
I don't,
church hall or wherever they were meeting mostly black folk and then Obama.
How everybody in the room had to go around and say why they were there or what
issue they were there for,
and he says with quite some directness that most people did,
what most people do,
they name a single issue.
It's about them.
It's about us,
right?
Not about the common good.
It's about us.
I want a better job.
I want health care.
I want that.
I want,
I want.
Okay,
fair enough.
And finally come around to an old black man is sitting there kind of at the end
of the isles and he's asked to,
why are you here?
Obama doesn't even name him.
He says,
I'm just here because Ashley brought me here.
I'm only here because of Ashley.
No,
Obama says in effect,
she develops it.
The end of the speech or refrain about not this time.
He says,
not this time.
We're not going to let race divide us this time.
Like Dubois has two figures hating to their death and hating their children's
children lived today.
Well,
here are our two children,
but not what he's reversed.
We've got a young white woman who should have been in the resentful white
working class and an old black man who no doubt grew up in Jim Crow and probably
have told story after story of the denigration or destruction of his dignity for
the first 45 years of his life.
But he's there because of Ashlyn.
Thank you.